Hollywood has lost a legend.
Los Angeles police say actor Mickey Rooney was with his family...
...when he died at home, Sunday.
Rooney's career spanned more than eight decades.
He first appeared in movies before he was 10.
Rooney's work included silent comedy shorts, musicals with Judy Garland...
...and his memorable performance with Spencer Tracy in Boys Town,...
...which came out in 1938.
He also received a Tony nomination for his role in Sugar Babies...
...which endured a run as the hottest ticket on Broadway.
Rooney was known for his colorful private life as well.
The actor was married eight times...
...including his first marriage to the glamorous actress Ava Gardner.
Rooney fathered seven sons and four daughters.
He was 93.